so what we ended on last time was I
rewrote like this kind of texture system
so that instead of being like all of
this kind of duplicated code we just
have a function now that takes in like
some kind of like statically defined
list of file Parts here so that we can
just load the textures kind of all at
once which just kind of cleans it up a
little bit and the reason why I
explained that I did that one of the
reasons is when you kind of look at the
code you know think about what's
important
because even though it's very important
for you to program in a way that
obviously suits the computer like the
computer or the device is going to be
executing your code like that is
probably the most important piece of
this puzzle at the end of the day the
code that you're writing is not
necessarily about you as a person like
oh what does my code look like even
though you can get quite creative and
artistic with it at the end of the day
your goal is kind of usually to make the
computer do a specific job so like
outside of like making your code look
like ASCII art or something like that
web programming CPUs here but then a
very close second to all of this is
how am I going to live on with my code
so you as a human you're going to have
to keep reading the code it's cool that
the computer can read it and execute it
hopefully in an efficient kind of you
know well structured away but then also
it's important to consider the human
side of the equation as well which is
how am I going to be able to keep
working with my code you know a really
good comparison I guess is in a
construction site you might have
scaffolding the scaffolding isn't there
to hold up the structure that you're
actually building like the building can
stay up fine that's okay but you still
have to work with the building and if
it's kind of at a great height you need
a way to be able to reach that height
and comfortably work it's very similar
in programming there's loss that we can
do as developers to kind of build that
scaffolding around our code base that's
why a lot of large software projects
have a lot of kind of auxiliary tools
that are used to test the code and make
sure everything works but specifically
what I'm talking about here is when we
kind of flip through this code and we
read all of it what is important to us
as the human because the computer can
have no problem executing this code
that's okay what we kind of rewrote it
into is not really fundamentally
different on an access execution level
but you can see that this looks very
different to this and specifically what
we've done is kind of taken this enemy
one enemy 2 enemy three enemy zero and
made it like the focal point almost feel
like I'm talking about composition for a
photography class or something but in a
way where composing this function to
look like this rather than this because
really the only piece of information we
care about are what are my file paths
that I have to manually input because
this person who has written this code
has decided to make a system where you
have to manually input every single
frame as a file path which we're not
going to talk about that in itself
that's just the way it's written we're
not going to change that I do have to
stop somewhere but we're kind of using
it as an example and so those kind of
two things the computer that's executing
the CPU that's executing your code
number one and then number two what is
it like from The Human Side of things
that's really what constitutes software
development and in the end that's
something you want to keep in mind at
all times